certain times and seasons in our lives
we need support in a way we didn't need
otherwise the holidays one of those
times that we see these picture-perfect
relationships on TV and then we go home
to reality and mother-in-laws and
father-in-laws and kids and grandkids
and all that kind of crazy stuff you
know first thing a very practical thing
is if you suspect that you're going to
have a tough holiday break your
tradition go do something different
whether it's serving in a homeless
shelter or whether it's going on a
cruise or just break your tradition
don't sit in the house where they were
and feel the pain and let the pain catch
you get ahead of it and do something
fresh give yourself to somebody who's in
trouble and I think that real
self-esteem comes from within and I
don't think it's wise to give your power
away to their reaction in order to
determine who you are that you have to
know within yourself who you are and to
hold on to that inside of yourself and
introduce yourself to them irrespective
to their reaction to you I think that's
too much power to give to another person
to allow their perception to control how
you feel about yourself and then the
other thing we are so inundated with so
many people close your circle get people
in your life that really care about you
the kinds of people that you would want
around you in your final moments because
those are the people who really matter
Jesus had him in an inner circle get you
an inner circle of people and they may
not even be related to you and they may
come from different worlds of walks of
life and this is how you test it the
people that when you walk in the room
their eyes light up uh the people that
make you feel warm you you talked about
coming to the room feeling comfortable
in the room those are the kind of people
you can pick through the menu of people
who you choose to be around with you
have that power and it's okay and you
don't have to say no to anybody it's who
you say yes to we are raising a
narcissistic society that is
self-consumed in what's in it for me
that we're from idea and you don't want
that in your children because one day
you're going to be depending on their
compassion when you're older and if you
didn't put it in them you can't get it
out my hopes are that we would narrow
our perspectives to what unites us
rather than what divides us we're all
going to have your unique interests that
will never change we will never agree
about everything but let's find out
what's common to us your love for
children your love for Life your need
for clean air and clean water just
simple things and let's coalesce our
relationships around what we have in
common rather than what divides us
there's more to unite us than there is
to divide us I want you to understand
little things matter and until you
understand that little things matter you
will never be able to fulfill your
destiny great people do little things
with excellence
great people don't just do great things
with Excellence they do little things
with Excellence they understand how
important it is to do normal things in
fact it is a sure sign that you're going
to end up in a great place when you give
great detail to little things when
something little goes wrong and it
bothers you when you want to make sure
that everything is right even though you
don't have a title and you don't have a
position and you don't have recognition
and you don't have Prestige but you have
a standard to which you hold yourself to
it's not about them it's about a
standard you hold yourself to and the
standard and the standard of Excellence
Excellence doesn't start when the lights
come on Excellence doesn't start when
the crowd gathers Excellence doesn't
come when everybody's watching
Excellence is nurtured in mediocrity in
ordinary days when you begin to
appreciate the power of the words before
you didn't give the attention to it that
it takes to win it that doesn't mean
that you are called to it it means that
you are starving your destiny of the
attention that it needs for you to
progress until you can appreciate
appreciate the process you will never
get to the problem some of you have a
life you have a business you have a
company you have a family you have an
identity that is in seedling form you're
not the nut you used to be but you're
not the tree you're gonna be
but until you learn how to appreciate
where you are in the process you won't
get the power to evolve to your ultimate
destiny
you're so busy starving the sapling
trying to get to the tree
that you cancel out the potential of
being a tree because you don't see where
you are you're in love with tomorrow
but you're neglecting today and when God
sees you neglecting today he will not
give you tomorrow until you are faithful
over the few you cannot be ruler over
the many so you need to take your eye
off of the tree and water what you got
now a great instrument in the hand of a
great artist produces great music
it does matter who's playing it it
matters who's swinging the golf course
hubs it matters who's running the
corporation
and we are attracted to people who are
masterful at what they do
and the center stage we have a piano a
baby grand piano
glistening shining and bright but it
cannot play itself
it is an opportunity if the right person
doesn't touch it it will never reach its
potential the piano has existed so long
that it will only give itself fully over
to somebody who has invested enough time
and effort in it and they know how to
get the most out of the same keyboard 88
keys on the keyboard but it's the
fingers that pluck it that control what
it can produce
so we need people who Mentor us into the
next dimension of Our Lives regardless
of our perspectives or our backgrounds
and understanding that embracing that
and resisting the gravitational pull to
condescend to what is acceptable by a
few and miss the broader populace of
entering into the mainstream of
possibilities and die
Beneath Your Potential is a tragedy a
mammoth proportion because you're not
just bearing the person you're bearing
the potential and a lot of people black
white brown Rich poor uh listening at us
right now run the risk of dying the
death of being normal or average rather
than being exceptional and being
fruitful to the full extent of your
potential wherever that takes you it's
not about necessarily being rich
it's about being fulfilled or filled
full to the fullest of the highest
expression of yourself and so I think
that that's something important it's
frustrating no matter where you park
your car and no matter the square
footage of your home to pull into the
driveway and feel like I never got to be
as far as I could see and and I think we
need people
to stimulate us and we have to keep
talking even though we're uncomfortable
and even though we get blowback and even
though we get the pull where you're
going to be disowned by your fellow
citizens don't stop because somebody
says you don't belong over there don't
drop the mic because Destiny is in front
of you and history it's behind you and
why would you live in your history when
you can excel in your destiny do it now
go for it go after it right now because
tomorrow you'll be in another season
and you will only eat in that season
what you plowed in this season
and so when I passed the mic to the Next
Generation I'm telling them this is not
a rehearsal
this is your recital
so when you hit the piano give it hell
because everybody's listening right now
and I don't think that we always tell
the Next Generation
how much it costs and how little time
you have
and and how important it is that you
don't spend your life crying about how
you feel and who wasn't there and who
didn't do this or that you don't have
time
to allow that that that pull to pull you
back down backwards
you have to be looking forward building
Forward Thinking forward going ahead
looking at your trees sizing up what
kind of table you're gonna make is it
going to be round or Square what tools
do you need what relationships do you
need the currency of relationships
it's your greatest resource
it's better than any dollar amount in
the world
you can have all the money in the world
you have no relationships you're a poor
man
if you have all the relationships in the
world you don't need any money because
everything you need will come through
your relationships we have not been
taught to Value the currency
of Human Resources
relationships because everything you're
going to be is incubated in the Cocoon
of who you're around